did you set out to make a film that was
so suspenseful or was it just because
you were there and you didn't know as
you were making it what was going to
happen as we were experiencing this for
five years there were so many twists and
turns and uncertainties going into it
that we always have sort of had this not
in our stomach not knowing what would
happen so we wanted to recreate that and
as we started working with Kate we're so
lucky that she's so good at creating
that because it is such a challenge I
think to to draw a story that is drawn
out over five years with so many
characters and so many different
settings and recreate that sense of
tension which I think we're really lucky
to have key and and in Cait you worked
on documentaries including the Jimmy
Carter man from planes so you had a
sense of how to tell a story without
giving everything away I guess there was
tension in the Edit we didn't know what
the end of our film was going to be we
were prepared for the worst but hoping
the best as you always say but and i
think that the other crucial thing is
that in the interviews that they didn't
know either so they were interviewed
before the decision had been made so we
began documenting it in May of 2009 I
think it was right after prop 8 past and
we knew somebody at the American
Foundation for equal rights so we went
through the foundation and then we
obviously had to get Ted and David on
board and we're so grateful to Ted and
David because it goes against every bone
in a lawyer's body to allow a
documentary crew to follow a process
this closely it's just not part of their
nature but I think both Ted and David
recognized the fact that way especially
when the trial wasn't going to be
broadcast that our documentary would be
a way of getting this story out to the
American people so they saw it more than
more as an educational tool but we were
filming hundreds of lawyers and the fact
that Ted and David led the charge and
said this documentary crew is going to
be here this is going to be a good thing
let's encourage transparency almost all
the lawyers were open to us filming at
all time over the years you know I've
gotten used to 200 300 400 hours but in
this case we didn't really have time for
me to look at everything although I
usually try to or watch as much as I can
or watch with the directors
that we can be selective we were
fortunate we had Karen boards who
watched everything and logged the
footage and she was was good in
isolating all those those highlights but
I think by the time all the highlights
and selects were boiled down maybe it
was maybe like 200 hours and we waited
through yeah and and then that's normal
that's one percent of that ends up on
the screen so how ruthless are you oh
it's more like I I'd like to think of it
more like sculpture that you're
whittling away and shaping it and
shaping and shaving and then it ends up
just exactly the way it was meant to be
I mean I I made two documentaries but
and I like those documentaries they were
really there were films that I loved
making but I had never worked on
something that was this meaningful and
this personal so Ben and I are both gay
Californians so the end of our end of
our movie you know has a direct effect
on what happens with our lives so by far
this was my biggest baby and we shared
this baby together so adding his
full-time job at my two other films
which I was making I was making the case
against Tate always took the back burner
because this was sort of our obsession
and you know we were very invested not
only in getting you know a great ending
to her film and what could happen with
our rights but we were so invested in
Kris and Sandy and Paul and Jeff's lives
especially by year five that it would
have been devastating for us if you know
gay Californians aside and filmmakers
aside if they hadn't gotten their
fairytale ending I think also I don't
think we set out realizing how personal
this was to us neither of us were
particularly passionate about the issue
of marriage or marriage equality and so
it was really I think sitting through
that trial and hearing the testimony and
that's why I became so important for us
to recreate what was happening in that
courtroom because it did I think for
everyone sitting in that courtroom you
see it clearly had no effect on David
Blankenhorn I had an effect on Chuck
Cooper who after the film was finished
it came out that his leather his
daughter is marrying another woman and
he's throwing her wedding so you have
their lead lawyer and their lead witness
now in support of same-sex marriage so
it affected people but especially I
think as gay Californians it
it spoke to truce and Kris and Sandy and
Paul and Jeff spoke two truths that I
don't think we had really heard
articulated in a way that made us
realize sort of the some of the things
that we were thinking about ourselves
that we didn't know we were thinking
about ourselves so it became more
personal i think as that four or five
years went on well I think we always
knew that the plaintiffs were the heart
and soul of the film and the their
preparation of those scenes where the
Lord's are preparing them for trial
we're really going to be the way that
their story was going to be told that's
how we told their their backgrounds
their life stories there luv storys met
their families and so that was always
going to be like the spine but then
always checking back in with the lawyers
in the case and the strategy and they
they all the the media strategy as well
and so it was it was great to have that
kind of balance because just when you
think well we've been in this law office
for too long then we could go to a scene
with with the families and so forth and
that was an or Chad Chad also in Chad
was like the engine and Christina they
were driving Ben and I decided very
early on as a common directorial vision
that we were not going to make an
advocacy fan we were not going to make a
movie about whether gay marriage was
right or wrong and tried to cover all
sides of an issue we were making a
character film about a team of people
and we were lucky to get the access to
that team of people and exclusive access
but there was a lot of confidentiality
involved with that and so if we had
tried to embarrass elves on the other
side too we would have definitely lost
access to the side that we did shoot so
from the very beginning we thought we're
making a film about characters these are
two love stories three love stories if
you include Ted and David and so that
was always our intent all along but but
but that being said we were thrilled
when David Blankenhorn wanted to
participate in our phone because we were
covering the expert witnesses from the
side that was the case against a and we
wanted to show what evidence was brought
in from the other side and he was the
only witness so we did get an interview
with the only evidence-based witness
expert witness that they brought in to
trial were so grateful that he was
willing to take part in it the idea that
this the Supreme Court is such an
important part of our government and
it's somewhat shrouded in mystery and we
had never seen a film that sort of went
behind the scenes of what it takes to
get a case to the Supreme Court and what
that process is so just little things
like that that sort of give color to
this really unusual it's a bizarre
process it's everyone should go to the
Supreme Court and watch an argument just
because it is so just it's just bizarre
it seems like it's from another century
in a sense but yeah I think we wanted to
capture you know this really sort of
unique world of it's a very specific
culture of people who argue these cases
Ted Olson specialized in others in Ted's
office for you get a white feather in
the Supreme Court for every case you
argue to the court and you had the
babies yeah something like 60 of them
for me I mean we've talked about this at
length for me the most surprising thing
is I mean Ben's from Indiana and from
Georgia so we grew up in parts of the
country that are not particularly LGBT
friendly definitely a time when marriage
equality wasn't even you know a twinkle
in our eyes so we just never even
entertained the idea that we were ever
get married as boys growing up it just
wasn't for people like us when prop
eight passed it was surprising you know
that was polling that it wouldn't pass
in the weeks leading up and then it did
but still when it passed it kind of made
sense to me that it passed you know it
only two states had gay marriage when
California when California legalized it
was the third state so it was just
normal that to me that Prop 8 passed it
is so surprising to me where we are in
the country right now when I look back
to my mindset from november two thousand
eight that now it would be totally
abnormal if a prop eight could pass to
me in california just wouldn't pass and
i would be shocked if it did and so the
the lengths that our country has come in
the last five years i mean there's a
partner film that we call changing tides
where you see the public opinion change
and you see republican politicians
coming out in favor of gay marriage I
mean when this case started dick cheney
was the only republican and prominent
republican a politician and favor of gay
marriage our president came out in favor
of gay marriage states for the first
time are legalizing gay marriage their
ballot initiatives states like Utah
Texas Ohio you know are legalizing gay
marriage right now Pennsylvania Oregon
so just the swiftness with which that
has happened is is the most surprising
factor to me